Every image you've seen of a black hole,
including this one,
is now science fiction.
Astronomers have successfully snapped
the first genuine picture of a black hole.
[music]
Black holes in their own don't look like very much.
They don't reflect light because
any light that falls into them can never escape.
And they don't emit any light that we can detect.
Those aren't the only reasons
black holes are hard to photograph.
Even though they're really, really massive--
they can be millions or billions of times
the mass of the Sun.
They don't take up that much space on the sky.
They've compressed all that mass
into a really tiny little space.
The closest being black hole to Earth
is at the center of the Milky Way,
which is 26,000 light-years away from us.
And so in order to be able to see something
of that size we need a telescope that
has a resolution that is powerful enough
that it could see a doughnut on the surface of the Moon.
The black hole illustrations we're all familiar with
aren't complete lies.
Plenty of data suggest that black holes exist.
Some even shoot jets into space that we can see
and spaghettify stars that get too close.
So far, the best evidence for these behemoths
has been her entourage.
They wrap huge amounts of gas
and like charged plasma around them.
And as that stuff is trying to fall into the black hole,
it can't all go in at once,
so it orbits super super super fast.
And the friction in that fast orbiting heats it white-hot.
Most illustrations focus on this accretion disk.
But now we're looking at the real deal
thanks to the event horizon telescope, or the EHT.
This monumental first image features the black hole
at the center of a galaxy called M87.
At more than 50 million light years from Earth,
it's farther away than
the black hole at the centre of the Milky Way
but more massive.
That makes it easier to image.
The picture shows the shadow of the black hole
on the glowing gas and plasma in the accretion disk.
The black hole shadow creates a silhouette
on the disk that outlines the point of no-return --
the event horizon.
Taking such a picture requires
a really, really big telescope.
The EHT uses a lot of smaller radio telescopes instead.
They work together using a technique called
very long baseline interferometry.
And what that does is it makes those telescopes
kind of act like one giant telescope.
Scientists analyzing the data can see
how the light waves detected by each telescope
line up with each other to figure out
what's light from the edge of the black hole
and what's noise.
The EHT's first image gives us
an up close look at the accretion disk,
plus two key bits of information --
the size and shape of the black hole's shadow.
And then that will be enough to answer
a lot of interesting astrophysical questions
about how black holes work,
how event horizons work
and what is going on there.
The big questions include:
how exactly do accretion discs form
and feed black holes?
Where the black hole jets originate?
And the oldie but always a goodie...
was Einstein right?
His general theory of relativity predicted
that event horizons could conceal
tiny massive objects like black holes.
The shape of this image that we see
is something that you can predict
using general relativity.
The EHT's closeup doesn't defy Einstein.
Our understanding of gravity still holds.
But there will be more to come.
The team hopes to take better and better images
of M87's black hole and others --
including the one at the center of the Milky Way,
Sagittarius A*.
Those images might have something new to say
about general relativity as well as
the physics theory that deals with very small objects,
quantum mechanics.
The two of them don't play well together.
We don't understand how gravity works
on sort of quantum levels.
And if we see something that differs
from our expectation,
That could help point us to
one of many theories that try to reconcile
quantum mechanics and general relativity.
It's also just cool.
Whether it's a pale blue dot
or pristine portrait of Pluto,
seeing has always offered us
a new perspective on the universe.
Humans are very visual,
and so we love having images.
And I think having an actual picture of a black hole
is just going to blow people's minds.
Hi! I'm Helen.
I make videos here at Science News.
If this video looks a little bit familiar to you,
it's because we released a version a few weeks ago.
At the time we thought that
the EHT's first image would be of Sagittarius A*,
the black hole at the center of the Milky Way.
But it turned out to be of M87's black hole instead.
So we decided to release a new version of the video
with the new results.
The EHT still hopes to get an image of Sagittarius A*.
It just won't be the first image
of a black hole ever released.
Am I going to like break continuity
if I roll up my sleeves?
Nah, I'm gonna start this one over.
This is hard.
I was just watching
the Great British Baking Show last night.
Umm.
They wear the same clothes two days in a row.
We'll go there, yeah.
I feel like it's wrong.
Sorry, yeah you can cut that. [Laughs]
So don't roll up your sleeves then.
Something like that...
[Laughing]
[music]